les poursuites ont initialement débuter
en décembre 2020 une coalition d'états
américains emmenés par le texas décide
de poursuivre en justice google selon
ses états le géant américain aurait
manipulé les ventes aux enchères
publicitaires afin d'évincer toute
concurrence
le 14 janvier dernier une nouvelle
version de la plainte a été déposée dans
un tribunal de new york elle vise aussi
meta la maison-mère de facebook les deux
firmes auraient passé un accord en 2018
afin d'asseoir leur domination sur le
marché publicitaire dans les documents
juridiques mis au jour on y apprend que
plusieurs cadres dirigeants de google
sont visés ainsi que la directrice des
opérations de facebook même si son nom
apparaît baril
ces négociations ont débouché en
septembre 2018 sur un accord entre
google et facebook signé par philips
linder vice président et directeur des
ventes et opérations de la branche
publicité de google et madame directrice
des opérations et membre du conseil
d'administration de facebook qui avait
elle même un temps dirigé la publicité
chez google le directeur général de
google sundar pichai ya aussi
personnellement approuvé les termes de
l'accord google a dénoncé une plainte je
cite truffé d'inexactitudes et sans
fondement juridique facebook aussi se
défend l' accord non exclusif passé avec
google et les accords similaires que
nous avons avec d'autres plateforme
d'enchères ont aidé à renforcer la
concurrence pour les placements
publicitaires
ses relations professionnelles
permettent à mme état de proposer plus
de valeur aux annonceurs tout en
compensant les éditeurs de façon
équitable tout le monde y gagne une
plainte qui vient enrichir une actualité
judiciaire déjà chargé pour les gars
femme le 6 janvier google et facebook
ont écopé d'amendés salées infligée par
la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés pour des
manquements à la loi informatique et
libertés le 13 janvier dernier un
rapport parlementaire a épinglé les deux
géants du web les appelant à plus de
transparence sur les accords noués avec
les éditeurs de presse dans le cadre de
la directive sur les droits voisins pour
rappel cette dernière est censé
contraindre les deux firmes à rémy airs
et les éditeurs et agences de presse
pour la reprise de leurs contenus sur
internet